all right folks we have an insane new
development in the echo Fox saga Rick
Fox one of the founders of echo Fox is
suing his former business partners
alleging they committed fraud breach of
fiduciary duty invasion of privacy
conspiracy defamation and caused
significant emotional distress to one
Rick Fox but there's something that's
way crazier than any of that in this
lawsuit Fox's warriors allege that one
of those business partners is addicted
to drugs and that drug addiction
basically has them indentured to AMA try
saunas the shareholder mused the racist
language that kicked this whole thing
off months ago you guys are not ready
for how crazy this is gonna get all
right let's do a quick recap on the
rosada a shareholder and echo fox use
some racist and threatening language and
communications with Jace Hall and Rick
Fox this led to increased scrutiny into
echo fox from Riot Games which in turn
led to an investigation that forced echo
Fox to sell their LCS lot now EG is the
proud owner of that slot so congrats EG
instead i want to talk about the new
thing we got a 162 page lawsuit that i
100% didn't print off these are blank
papers hey this guy's a big throw D but
I have read the whole thing and it
alleges some pretty wild stuff about
echo Fox and the business partners that
found it this is gonna start a little
slow but stick around we're gonna get to
the drug-fueled party's pretty soon
allegedly this all started - when Rick
Fox met i'ma try SATA for the second
time in 2015 where apparently Bryce
oughta had this all planned out the
lawsuit says that Rick Fox was
orchestrated and manipulated by rise
odda who was attempting to befriend Fox
in an effort to use his personal
connections fame and influence for his
own benefit it also says that rosada
told Rick Fox a heartbreaking story that
he recently got divorced and he was down
on his luck and so Rick Fox took pity on
him and wanted to help him get back on
his feet
so Fox's lawyers say that this is all
part of Rosetta's playbook they say that
he does this all the time
he asks or offers mentorship and then
gets involved in your business dealings
and starts to mess up your company for
his own personal gain
meanwhile the lawyers say that Rick Fox
fell for this alleged scheme because he
wanted to learn from Roy sadhas'
business experience so according to the
lawsuit that is how rosada and Rick Fox
got in business together in the first
place they formed the company called
vision venture part
which ended up being the ownership group
for echo fox alongside some other faults
from Jace Hall and stron sklavos and
we're gonna get into struttin sklavos
pretty soon I want to quote from the
lawsuit here because this is hilarious
quote it took time to peel away the
layers of lies and deception but Fox
eventually realized that he had gone to
business with two very bad guys rosada
and sklavos I just feel like the phrase
very bad guys is a little weird in what
is gonna turn out to be a multi-million
dollar lawsuit but more importantly
apparently this revelation of how bad
they were happen pretty recently Fox's
lawyers allege that rosada and sklavos
were manipulating the finances behind
the scenes now to refresh you guys these
allegations have come up before Rick Fox
has alleged in the past that rosada and
sklavos were self-dealing through a
complicated series of loan and debt that
eventually gave them more money than
they put into echovox the rest of the
timeline is pretty standard at this
point Fox's lawyers say that right sada
will snap if he's pushed or someone's
close to figuring him out which is
allegedly what led to the racial slurs
and threatening language he used in
conversations with Jace Hall and Rick
Fox and again when we found out about
those that kicked off this whole thing
now here's the new part of this lawsuit
though and this gets insane so stick
with me Fox's lawyers allege that
sklavos was putting echo Fox in a
tailspin by taking out more and more
debt and this was all happening because
he had erratic behavior because of his
quote drug-fueled lifestyle I want to
stop for a second and I put into
perspective we've done three videos
about this this is gonna be the fourth
one this is when we get to the drugs I
wanted this look at the beginning this
is insane but what do I want more than
anything else in this entire world yes
crap oh okay I thought you were gonna
say pizza or yeah no no buffalo egg you
are crap now there is no evidence for
this anywhere in the lawsuit and they
don't actually cite anything maybe they
have testimony maybe they have evidence
that wasn't in the lawsuit now but the
fact the matter is it kind of comes out
of nowhere
alright so apparently Rick Fox worried
that sklavos who has an investor who
came in to echo Fox a little bit later
than the rest of them he was a part
owner of the San Jose Sharks until 2015
anyway Rick Fox was worried that this
erratic behavior was because of all the
drugs that he was secretly doing [ __ ]
lawyers go on to alleged sklavos
is basically indebted and quote
effectively indentured to Rai sada
because he needs to support his quote
drug-fueled lifestyle
this dude is allegedly some sort of
financial slave to ama try sada because
he needs to buy drugs that is nuts this
is this is what this lawsuit was written
by somebody who has never done drugs in
their life which can be evidenced by
this next statement they allege that
quote rosada did illegal drugs with
sklavos - in order to build their
relationship which is what let's Cabos
to invest in echo fox in the first place
and set up this whole plan did illegal
drugs has anyone ever said that in their
lives what you need one please one what
one one rock rap a crack crowd finally
they alleged it sklavos took out a two
million dollar loan from Vision Venture
Partners again that's echo Fox's
ownership group in order to pay for the
drugs and all the parties he loved all
right let's run this back for a second
and I want to go through these events in
the order that the lawsuit alleges they
happened in fox's alleging that sklavos
and rosada did some illegal drugs
together which let rise out a pulse
clavos into echo fox as a major investor
and begin to do some fraud which I guess
is a plan they came up with while they
were on drugs I don't know anyway
sklavos then got addicted to those drugs
and became indentured to Izod in order
to support his drug habit and all the
parties he was addicted to oh also that
whole thing about sklavos allegedly
being indentured to rise oughtta well
fox's lawyers allege that rice auda has
a lien on sklavos his house that means
that sklavos owes rise out of some money
and until he pays that money back Rosato
literally owns his home again if any of
this is true it is insane there's also
some other pretty crazy business
allegations that are a little bit less
you know drug fueled fox's lawyers
allege that after sklavos in rosada
promised a yankees a dilution proof
share and fo fox meaning that their
percentage stake in the company would
never go down despite more people
investing into it they went around
behind their backs and formed two more
companies to raise money without kind of
breaking that agreement but still
diluting their ownership share the
lawyers also alleged that that two
million dollar loan that's call those a
legend
took out to pay for his drugs and
parties was at below market rates which
effectively let him pocket two million
dollars of investment money there are
over a dozen causes of action in this
lawsuit which is to say what Rick Fox's
lawyers are asking for and many of them
stake to damages as well over 10 million
dollars each there's also some pretty
nutty stuff in the causes of action -
including allegations that rice auto was
spying on Rick Fox including hacking
into his email and dialing at the
conference called without telling anyone
I read this entire lawsuit and honestly
every time I got another sentence in the
rabbit hole but even deeper the back
like hundred pages are another lawsuit
that has brought forward as evidence of
how rosada has allegedly done this
before to other business partners in
Kansas included in that or allegations
that rise odda has a PR team that
actively suppresses negative stories
about him and pushes out positive ones
about him constantly and also okay and
this is my favorite part
other than the drugs I guess the lawsuit
alleges that sklavos basically gave rise
Oda a job at vision Venture Partners
without getting approval from the board
this job was very quickly raised to a
$350,000 a year salary with health
benefits in a $100,000 budget for meals
and entertainment that he never had to
get approved the contractor I thought
assigned also said that the company had
to pay rent utilities everything on his
Beverly Hills home which according to
the lawsuit was $20,000 in a rent alone
plus and this is hilarious
the lawsuit notes that rosada also got
to keep any membership rewards or points
from any credit cards he used even
though all the funds were being paid for
by the company that is weird but very
specific to have in your lawsuit all
right this has all been insane we have
allegations of drug use of parties of
spying and that's not even the half of
it
I know this has been a lot to take in
but I want to give you an update on
what's happening with this whole Rick
Fox versus AMA tries on a saga honestly
we can do a video about each and every
cause of action here they are all just
that crazy but at the end of the day the
lawsuit alleges that rights oughta
stands to make around nineteen million
dollars from the sale of echo Fox's LC s
slot on top of the ten million dollars
he's earned from selling his ownership
share in the company to Rick Fox and
Koli Jones last year heading up all the
points of action Rick Fox's lawyers
claimed at least
an excess of damages of sixty two point
five million dollars and at the end of
all of this that is how much Rick Fox
stands to make if he wins this lawsuit
now a judge or jury could give him more
or less than that but the fact remains
this is the money he's fighting for not
the money from the sale of the echo fox
law not any revenue echo fox was making
this is it this is what rick fox will
have in the future and that's where we
are today
the lawsuit requests a jury trial which
it remains to be seen if a judge will
even grant that but whatever happens
this is a ton of money and some wild
allegations whenever we learn about will
make sure we update you and if we find
out about any drug fueled parties you
can be certain we'll have a video about
that too i had a friend once she
discovered that her brother a younger
brother was smoking marijuana and but
she found this out by seeing a bag of
weed under his bed and she opened this a
ziploc bag of weed and ate a [ __ ] bud
it was just like why didn't you do that
usually i didn't know what they were
like but why didn't you do that that's
not a good answer anyway
[Music]